we didn't think they would just totally
abandon the running game and
we had a real nice plan if they're going
to run it
so
we have to be able to adapt better
to make sure that we can we can turn it
around faster you know
it's very easy for pete carroll to so
casually point out that he was out
coached on the day that news broke of
his latest contract extension right i
mean
maybe it may have been last week he'd
have been a little more subtle but we
want to wait for the eyes to be dotted
and the t's to be crossed on all
signatures
before pete carroll comes out and says
yeah you know what just wasn't our day
we thought they'd run they passed oh
well them's the brakes
yeah no doubt mike it you know
when you look at the where these teams
were i mean what buffalo does best is
pass the ball they're ranked fourth in
passing what seattle does worst is
defend the pass they're 32nd against the
pass which is why the 32nd overall
so why you would go into that game
thinking that buffalo is possibly going
to run i don't know and they ran 64
plays and only 19 of those were rushes
and some of those were late after they
were trying to run down some clock so
they went in with the intent to pass the
ball they did it they did it really well
and and josh allen i'm gonna say it he
outplayed russell wilson russell wilson
had four turnovers and that was a big
reason that this team didn't win the
game and if you're looking at mvp i
think the mvp race just got a lot closer
after this game mike
yeah i agree with you completely and
look i
i don't know who the favorite currently
is i guess it would be patrick mahomes
the guy that we take for granted
there's one guy there's one guy
and
uh i i i i he's not there yet
but if dalvin cook keeps generating 200
plus yards from scrimmage week in and
week out and the vikings somehow pull
their way into playoff contention and
get there it'll remind me a lot of
adrian peterson in 2012. now cook's
gonna have to get 1800 1900 plus rushing
yards he's on pace frankly for over 1800
even though he missed a game and a half
but i i say we we don't completely rule
him out it could be all these great
quarterbacks cancel each other out
there'll be one non-quarterback for
people to vote for if he keeps this up
he can steal this thing
yeah and mike you know one thing you
look at you look at the team with the
best record and you look at their
quarterback right well right now the
team with the best record is the
pittsburgh steelers and we're not
looking at ben roethlisberger and he
played pretty well yesterday but you
know why we're not looking at him
because that defense is so good and i
think that's what's going to happen to
pittsburgh and ben roethlisberger if it
comes down to it even if they go 16-0 i
don't know that people are going to
automatically vote for ben
roethlisberger because that defense is
so good and so i think that's a problem
for him in the mvp race but you know
aaron rodgers maybe if they win and end
up with the best record in the nfc maybe
he's the guy you look to but i think
it's totally up in the air right now and
i'm with you i would vote for patrick
mahomes probably today if i had to
russell wilson is right there he's still
in the race but i do think it's changed
my opinion uh after this game just the
way he turned the ball over russell
wilson's got to play well the rest of
the way and they're asking him back to
how bad the defense was they're asking
him to be superman every single week and
it's a lot to ask for a quarterback and
he just he he obviously can't do that
every week what they're asking him to do
that defense has got to be better which
is why you look at a team like that for
tak mckinley because they've got to do
something to help that defense and they
were better with jamal adams they were
better with carlos dunlop but they still
ranked 32nd and they still gave up over
400 passing yards
currently russell wilson is plus 110 for
the mvp that means you bet 100 you win
110 bucks mahomes plus 250 aaron rodgers
plus 400. if i were able to wager and
we're not allowed to not that i would
want to anyway because i'm too cheap to
lose money i'd think about dalvin cook
at plus eight thousand i'd i'd be
willing i'd be willing to put a saw buck
i think that's ten bucks on dalvin cook
at plus eight thousand absolutely
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports